AVERAGE INCREASE INCLUDING
IDAHO, OKLAHOMA, AND WYOMING.
>> Tucker: TRACE GALLAGHER,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT.
THOSE ARE THE NUMBERS AS OF
TONIGHT.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT HAPPENS
NEXT, THAT’S WHAT APPEARS TO BE
A PRECINCT FULL OF QUESTIONS.
WHEN WILL NEW YORK CITY REACH
THE PEAK OF ITS OUTBREAK?
NEW YORK OF COURSE BEING THE
PLACE WITH THE MOST CASES IN
THIS COUNTRY AND YOU THINK THE
EPIDEMIOLOGIST COULD ANSWER THAT
QUESTION WITH SOME PRECISION BUT
AS IT TURNS OUT, IT CAN’T.
PREDICTED THE PEAK WOULD COME
THIS WEEK AHEAD OF APRIL 15TH,
THE STATE’S HEALTH COMMISSIONER
MEANWHILE THOUGHT LATE APRIL OR
EARLY MAY.
THE PREDICTIONS DIFFERED BY A
FULL MONTH AT A TIME WHEN
NEW YORK HAS QUARANTINED AND
PEOPLE ARE STILL DYING, THAT IS
A VERY BIG RANGE OF ANSWERS.
SUMMED UP THE CURRENT STATE OF
KNOWLEDGE THIS WAY, "IN REALITY,
WE DON’T KNOW."
WE DON’T KNOW.
PEOPLE WERE HOSPITALIZED FOR
CORONAVIRUS, THE HIGHEST NUMBER
SO FAR RECORDED.
THE NEXT DAY, AND A TOTAL DROP
TO 1,095 AND THEN ON SUNDAY, AND
FELL TO 358.
NEW HOSPITALIZATIONS HAVE PICKED
UP ONCE AGAIN BUT STILL FAR
BELOW LAST THURSDAY’S PEAK, IF
THIS TREND HOLDS, BUT IF IT
DOES, THE WORST MAY ALREADY BE
OVER FOR NEW YORK.
ALL OF THIS HAS COME AS A
SURPRISE TO OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
AUTHORITIES AND A WELCOME
SURPRISE TO THOSE WATCHING FOR
THE INSTITUTE FOR HEALTH METRICS
AND EVALUATION IS WELL-REGARDED
RESEARCH CENTER RUN FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF WASHINGTON.
HAS PRODUCED PREDICTIONS FOR THE
COURSE OF THIS EPIDEMIC HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES AS WELL AS
OTHER COUNTRIES.
THEIR MODEL HAS DONE PERHAPS ANY
OTHER PIECE OF ACADEMIC RESEARCH
TO SHAPE OUR RESPONSE TO THE
CORONAVIRUS CRISIS.
SO ACCURATE HAS THAT MODEL BEEN?
HERE ARE SOME NUMBERS.
INITIALLY, THEY PREDICTED THAT
ON APRIL 4TH, THE STATE OF
NEW YORK WOULD REQUIRE 65,000
HOSPITAL BEDS TO HANDLE INFECTED
PATIENTS.
THE LOW-END ESTIMATE WAS NEARLY
48,000 BEDS AND THEY HAD FEWER
THAN 16,000 HOSPITALIZATIONS
FELL BELOW THE MODEL’S
PROJECTIONS AS WELL, OVER THE
WEEKEND THEY UPDATED ITS MODEL,
ACROSS THE COUNTRIES AND YET
THEY ARE STILL SIGNIFICANTLY
OVERSTATED.
FOR EXAMPLE, TODAY WHICH IS
APRIL 7TH, THEY PREDICT THAT
NEW YORK WILL NEED 25,000
HOSPITAL BEDS.
AS OF THIS MORNING, IT WAS JUST
UNDER 17,500.
THE NEW MODEL ALSO PREDICTED
THAT AS OF TODAY, ALMOST 6,600
PEOPLE WOULD BE IN INTENSIVE
CARE AND ACTUAL NUMBERS JUST
UNDER 4600.
IN FLORIDA, IT PREDICTED 4,000
PEOPLE WOULD BE HOSPITALIZED.
THE REALITY IS THAT NOT EVEN
2,000 ARE IN IT WASN’T JUST
FLORIDA AND NEW YORK.
THEY GOT IT WRONG IN STATE AFTER
STATE AFTER STATE.
FOR AMERICA, THIS IS GREAT NEWS
AND WE SHOULD CELEBRATE IT.
IT’S MUCH BETTER THAN WE
THOUGHT.
SO ON THE QUESTION OF TOTAL
DEATHS, THE MODEL HAS BEEN MORE
ACCURATE, THOUGH IT STILL TENDS
TO OVERSHOOT.
YESTERDAY, THEY PREDICTED 784
DEATHS PER NEW YORK.
FINISH THE DAY WITH ABOUT 600.
CRITICS ABOUT 200 DEATHS TODAY
AND SADLY, SEEMS LIKE WE’LL
FINISH SOMEWHERE AROUND THAT
NUMBER.
BUT THAT MAY NOT BE THE WHOLE
STORY.
THERE IS NEW WANTS WITHIN THOSE
NUMBERS BECAUSE THERE ALWAYS IS
IN SOCIAL SCIENCE.
FOR MANY YEARS, THE CDC HAS
TRACKED THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
VISITS OF AMERICANS WHO DIE
EVERY WEEK FOR PNEUMONIA AND
THAT NUMBER HAS COME IN FAR
LOWER THAN AT THE SAME MOMENT IN
PREVIOUS YEARS.
HOW COULD THAT BE?
IT IS ENTIRELY POSSIBLE THAT
DOCTORS ARE CLASSIFYING
CONVENTIONAL PNEUMONIA DEATHS AS
COVID-19 DEATHS WHICH WAS MEAN
IT’S BEING CREDITED FOR
THOUSANDS OF DEATHS THAT WOULD
HAVE OCCURRED IF THE VIRUS NEVER
APPEARED HERE.
WE DON’T KNOW THAT FOR CERTAIN
BUT IT IS CERTAINLY WORTH
CONSIDERING.
NO ONE KNOWS EXACTLY WHY THE
MODEL PREDICTED SO MANY MORE
HOSPITALIZATIONS THAN WE HAVE
ACTUALLY HAD.
YOU WILL HEAR PEOPLE SAY THAT
THIS IS EVIDENCE THAT THE
SHUTDOWNS AND SOCIAL DISTANCING
MUST BE WORKING.
BUT NOT SO FAST, THEY WERE BUILT
INTO THE MODEL THEY’VE ALREADY
BEEN TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT WE ARE
STILL DOING FAR BETTER THAN WHAT
EPIDEMIOLOGY EXPERTS BELIEVE IS
A BEST-CASE SCENARIO SO, SO AS
WE MOVE FORWARD, HOW DID THIS
HAPPEN?
IT IS POSSIBLE THE VIRUS IS JUST
LESS DEADLY THAN WE FEARED IT
WAS ARE LESS LIKELY TO SEND
PEOPLE TO THE HOSPITAL.
MAYBE IT SPREADS LESS EASILY
THAN WE THOUGHT IT DATA MAY BE
IT SPREADS MORE EASILY AND THE
NUMBER OF ASYMPTOMATIC CARRIERS
IS HIGHER THAN WE KNEW.
ALL OF THOSE REASONABLE
THEORIES, WE DON’T KNOW WHICH
ONE COULD BE TRUE.
THEN THERE’S THIS, MIT ECONOMIST
SAID AMERICANS ARE FOLLOWING
SOCIAL DISTANCING GUIDELINES
MORE EFFECTIVELY THAN
AUTHORITIES EVER IMAGINE THEY
WOULD AND THAT’S ANOTHER
POTENTIAL EXPLANATION.
WHATEVER’S HAPPENING, THIS
EPIDEMIC APPEARS TO BE DOING
LESS DAMAGE THAN ANTICIPATED AND
IT IS RECEDING MORE QUICKLY.
NOT SO LONG AGO, SOME OF OUR
LEADERS SEEMED ON THE VERGE OF
PANIC.
FROM MARCH 24TH, GOVERNOR CUOMO
OF NEW YORK DESCENDED INTO A
STATE OF FRENZY MIGHT DISMISS
THE FEDERAL ASSISTANCE NEW YORK
HAD RECEIVED AS GROSSLY
INEFFICIENT.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF INNOCENT
NEW YORKERS WERE GOING TO DIE,
HE SAID, THEY WILL CHOKE TO
DEATH WHILE DOCTORS DO NOTHING
TO HELP THEM.
WATCH.
>> FAMOUS AS WE ARE SENDING 400
VENTILATORS.
REALLY?
WHAT AM I GOING TO DO WITH 400
VENTILATORS WHEN I NEED 30,000?
YOU PICK THE 26,000 PEOPLE WHO
WERE GOING TO DIE BECAUSE HE
ONLY SENT 400 VENTILATORS.
>> Tucker: YOU PICK THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE GOING TO DIE?
IT WAS EFFECTIVE THEATER BUT IT
WAS AWFUL, WHAT A HORRIFYING
THOUGHT THAT WAS.
AS RECENTLY AS LAST FRIDAY,
APRIL 3RD, GOVERNOR CUOMO
THREATENED TO USE THE
NATIONAL GUARD TO SEE HIS
VENTILATORS FROM FACILITIES
UPSTATE.
THAT’S HOW BADLY NEW YORK NEEDED
THEM.
EXCEPT HE DIDN’T NEED THEM.
AS IT TURNED OUT, NEW YORK HAS
MANY MORE BEDS AND VENTILATORS
THAN IT NEEDS.
>> EQUIPMENT, THE PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT, VENTILATORS WHERE WE
ARE STRETCHING AND MOVING, BUT
EVERY HOSPITAL HAS WHAT THEY
NEED TODAY.
>> Tucker: SO MISCALCULATIONS
LIKE THE ONES YOU JUST SAW
PLAYED OUT ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND STATE AFTER STATE.
ON MARCH 14TH, FOR EXAMPLE, THE
GOVERNOR OF OREGON WARNED THAT
HER STATE’S 688 VENTILATORS
WOULDN’T BE NEARLY ENOUGH TO
HANDLE THE COMING SURGE OF
CORONAVIRUS CASES.
TURNS OUT SHE GOT IT BACKWARD.
OREGON HAD MORE VENTILATORS THAN
IT NEEDED SOMEONE APRIL 4TH,
GOVERNOR BROWN SHIPPED 152
NEW YORK WHICH BASED ON CURRENT
TRENDS MAY NOT NEED THEM EITHER.
ONCE AGAIN, WE HAVE TO CELEBRATE
ALL OF THIS.
YOU ARE HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE A
GODSEND FOR THIS COUNTRY AND AS
AWFUL AS THIS EPIDEMIC HAS BEEN
AND WILL BE AT LEAST SO FAR IT
HASN’T BEEN THE DISASTER THAT WE
FEARED.
OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM HASN’T
COLLAPSED, THAT WAS THE KEY
CONCERN EXCEPT IN A HANDFUL OF
PLACES, HAS BECOME VERY CLOSE.
PATIENTS ARE NOT DYING ALONE IN
THE HALLWAYS OF EMERGENCY ROOMS
WITH PHYSICIANS TO OVERWHELM TO
TREAT THEM.
HAPPENS IN OTHER COUNTRIES, IT
IS NOT HAPPENING HERE.
THANK GOD FOR THAT.
ALL OF THIS MEANS THAT THE
SHORT-TERM CRISIS, THE ONES THAT
WE WORRIED ABOUT SO FERVENTLY IN
WHICH PRESSURE ON HOSPITALS GREW
SO EXPONENTIALLY DAY BY DAY,
THAT SHORT-TERM CRISIS MAY HAVE
PASSED.
HE LOOKED LIKE IT MAY HAVE.
NOW IT’S TIME TO LOOK AHEAD.
THE VIRUS IS DOING LESS SYSTEMIC
DAMAGE TO OUR SYSTEM, THEN
PRESUMABLY WE CAN BEGIN TO
CONSIDER HOW TO IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF THE REST, THE COUNTLESS
AMERICANS WHO HAVE BEEN
GRIEVOUSLY HURT BY THIS.
HAD A WEEK AT 17 MILLION OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE CITIZENS BACK TO
WORK?
THAT’S OUR TASK.
OTHER COUNTRIES ARE ALREADY HARD
AT WORK DOING IT.
ADJUSTED FOR POPULATION,
DENMARK’S CORONAVIRUS OUTBREAK
HAS BEEN ALMOST AS PRECISELY AS
SEVERE AS OURS HAS IN U.S.
IN DENMARK, SCHOOLS AND
DAY CARE CENTERS ARE PLANNED TO
OPEN UP NEXT WEEK.
THEY OUTBREAK IN AUSTRIA HAS
ALSO BEEN SIMILAR IN SCOPE TO
AMERICA PER CAPITA.
THEY ARE, THE GOVERNMENT PLANS
TO LET THEM OPEN APRIL 14
FOLLOWED BY LARGE DOORS ON
MAY 1ST AND POTENTIALLY
RESTAURANTS AND SCHOOLS IN THE
MIDDLE OF MAY.
SO THAT’S WHAT THEY’RE DOING.
WE ARE NOT DOING THAT HERE.
WE ARE NOT EVEN TALKING ABOUT
DOING THAT BECAUSE WERE NOT
ALLOWED TO.
ANY DISCUSSION OF HOW WE MIGHT
TRANSITION OUT OF THE SHUT DOWN
BACK INTO NORMAL LIFE FOR SOME
REASON HAS BECOME TABOO IN THIS
COUNTRY.
GO AHEAD AND RAISE THE QUESTION,
YOU’LL FIND IT ANNOUNCED AS A
TOOL OF WALL STREET WHO DOESN’T
CARE ABOUT HUMAN LIFE UP OFF AND
DENOUNCED BY PRO-CHOICE
ACTIVISTS WHO WERE HAPPY CASH
AND THE LAYERS OF IRONY ARE
BOTTOMLESS.
WE SHOULDN’T BE SURPRISED BY ANY
OF THIS.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
HEALTHY PUBLIC DEBATE IS
REPLACED BY MEMES AND MINDLESS
PARTISANS ON SOCIAL MEDIA
DEFINING THE TERMS OF ALLOWABLE
CONVERSATION AND SO WE PLOWED
FORWARD AS IF THE FLAWED MODELS
WEREN’T FLAWED AT ALL.
BECAUSE OF THE REALITY OF WHAT
IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING IN OUR
HOSPITALS SHOULD PLAY NO ROLE AT
ALL AND THE DECISIONS WE MAKE
GOING FORWARD.
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI HAS ANNOUNCED
THAT AMERICANS MUST BRACE FOR 18
MONTHS OF SHUTDOWNS AT THE
ABSOLUTE MINIMUM AND IF A
VACCINE ISN’T FOUND, IT COULD GO
ON FOREVER.
>> IF THAT MEANS ACTING LIKE
THERE NEVER WAS A CORONAVIRUS
PROBLEM, I DON’T THINK THAT’S
GOING TO HAPPEN UNTIL WE DO HAVE
A SITUATION WHERE YOU CAN
COMPLETELY PROTECT THE
POPULATION.
YOU WANT TO GET TO
PRECORONAVIRUS, THAT MIGHT NOT
EVER HAPPEN IN THE SENSE OF THE
FACT THAT THE THREAT IS THEY ARE
ARE.
>> Tucker: SO LIFE MAY NEVER
RETURN TO NORMAL IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WE MAY NEVER REGAIN WHAT WE’VE
LOST.
YOU’RE HEARING A LOT OF PEOPLE
SAY THAT ALL OF A SUDDEN AND
IT’S BECOMING A SPECIES OF
CONVENTIONAL WISDOM.
ZEKE EMANUEL EXPLAINED THAT
AMERICA WOULD BE SHUTTERED FOR
18 MONTHS AT LEAST.
>> REALISTICALLY, COVID-19 WILL
BE HERE FOR THE NEXT 18 MONTHS
OR MORE.
WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO RETURN TO
NORMALCY UNTIL WE FIND A VACCINE
FOR EFFECTIVE MEDICATIONS.
I KNOW THAT IS DREADFUL NEWS TO
HEAR.
HOW ARE PEOPLE SUPPOSED TO FIND
WORK IF THIS GOES ON IN SOME
FORM FOR A YEAR AND A HALF?
IS ALL THAT ECONOMIC PAIN WORTH
TRYING TO STOP COVID-19?
THE TRUTH IS, WE HAVE NO CHOICE.
WE PREMATURELY END THAT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING ON THE OTHER
MEASURES, KEEPING IT AT BAY,
DEATHS COULD SKYROCKET INTO THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS IF NOT THE
MILLION.
WE CANNOT RETURN TO NORMAL UNTIL
THERE IS A VACCINE.
CONFERENCES, CONCERTS, SPORTING
EVENTS, RELIGIOUS SERVICES,
DINNER AT A RESTAURANT, NONE OF
THAT WILL RESUME UNTIL WE FIND A
VACCINE, TREATMENT, OR CURE.
>> Tucker: YOU CAN’T GO TO
CHURCH UNTIL WE HAVE A VACCINE.
THE TRUTH IS, WE HAVE NO CHOICE.
HEARD THAT BEFORE?
THAT’S A FAMILIAR PHRASE IN
WASHINGTON AND IT OUGHT TO YOU
NERVOUS.
ALTHOUGH MY ORDERS WITHOUT
QUESTION OR COMPLAINT OR A
MILLION PEOPLE WILL DIE.
THE OCEANS WILL RISE, THE
POLAR BEARS WILL PERISH, THE
HUMAN RACE ITSELF WILL GO
EXTINCT.
OKAY, MAY BE.
THESE ARE SMART PEOPLE, WE
SHOULD HEAR THEM OUT, BUT THESE
ARE ALSO BIG DECISIONS.
HISTORY CHANGING DECISIONS WITH
CONSEQUENCES WE CAN’T EVEN BEGIN
TO ANTICIPATE THIS FAR OUT.
BEFORE WE GO AHEAD AND ALTER OUR
LIVES AND OUR COUNTRY FOREVER,
IT IS FAIR TO ASK ABOUT THE
NUMBERS, THEIR NUMBERS, THE ONES
WE ACTED ON THE FIRST TIME THAT
TURNED OUT TO BE COMPLETELY
WRONG.
HOW DID THEY SCREW THAT UP SO
THOROUGHLY?
THAT IS A FAIR QUESTION.
THEY CAN ANSWER THAT QUESTION,
SLOWLY, RATIONALLY IN A WAY THAT
MAKES SENSE AND SUGGEST A DEEPER
HUMILITY GOING FORWARD AS THEY
MAKE MORE DECISIONS, THAN THAT’S
ADEQUATE, THAT’S ENOUGH.
THEY ARE ALLOWED TO MAKE MORE
PUBLIC POLICY DECISIONS BUT IF
THEY CAN’T ANSWER THAT QUESTION,
IF THEY DODGE OR ATTACK THE
PEOPLE WHO ASK IT, THEN YOU KNOW
THEY ARE DISQUALIFIED FOREVER